tu vas le voir conseillera puis lucas
appréhende mais il sait pourquoi il est
là
en 2018 le jeune gendarme est en
déplacement dans le sud de la france en
sortant de boîte de nuit ils essayent
d'empêcher un bol de vélo il reçoit
alors plusieurs coups de couteau qui ont
failli lui coûter la vie aujourd'hui il
veut tourner la page
mes proches déjà qu'ils ont forcément
été très affecté donc c'est aussi en
quelque sorte pour eux parce que je sais
ne donne pas forcément
voir ses cicatrices quand et même au
delà de ça quelque chose que j'ai du mal
à accepter au début c'est un pendant la
rééducation j'ai fait pas mal de piscine
et laisser le regarder des gens fait et
même surtout des enfants là tu as toi tu
viens donc recouvrir ses cicatrices par
des dessins réalisés avec le client
comme katrina la déesse de la mort au
mexique une façon de transformer la
tragédie en une nouvelle histoire plus
belle plus romantique ce qui m'a plutôt
intéressant dans ce projet là en fait
c'était la difficulté elle met en place
le fait qu'ils aient quand même quelque
chose très traumatiques et puis
quelqu'un a aidé parce qu' il est plus
apaisé sur l'histoire mais quand il nous
a contactés c'était beaucoup plus à vif
pour lui et c'était très important de
les recouvrer 1 il a mis longtemps fait
à nous en parler des c'est une épreuve
un choc tous franchissent les portes de
son salon avec un récit pesant un récit
qui évolue entre la prise de rendez vous
et la séance ici aucune date disponibles
avant 2025
il ya des gens qui vont être bien fixés
qui vont arriver quand même justement
avec au moins la bonne idée de base qui
est là nous fait après grappiller sur le
chemin du projet facilement et d'autres
où justement c'est un peu plus compliqué
pareil en fait ça dépend aussi parfois
des histoires de vie
des fois c'est pas encore assez stable
la situation et pas assez posé et donc
le projet n'arrivent pas à ressortir je
pense déjà la douleur du rêve
lucas devra s'armer de patience encore
une dizaine d'heures à passer sous les
aiguilles mais aucun doute son tatouage
l'aidera à l'essai cette histoire
derrière lui